الرئيس الصيني في الرياض في زياره رسميه
هي الاولى له الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه منذ عام 2016 في اطار تعزيز
الوفود العملاق الاسيوي في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وسيشارك ايضا في قيمتين خليجيه
صينيه وعربيه صينيه يحضرهما قاده دول
ان توفر القمه للجانبين فرصه لاستكشاف
افكار لمواصله تطوير علاقتهما
والدخلي في شركه نستراتيجيه صينيه عربيه
وفي برنامج هذه الزياره التي تستغرق ثلاثه
ايام لقاءات ثنائيه عديده مع العاهل
السعودي وولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان
النفت سيكون موضوعا مهما بين اكبر
مستوردين واكبر مصدر للذهب الاسود في
العالم
السعوديه والصين قد يوقعني على اكثر من 20
فقيه بقيمه 28 مليار يورو صفقات تسمح حتى
للرياض بالاعلان عن فائض في الميزانيه
لاول مره منذ 10 سنوات
لاول مره في تاريخ المملكه يتخطى حاجز
التريليون دولار العام القادم
الارقام امامنا ثلاثه فاصله 8-6
وتاتي هذه الزياره وسطوتر في العلاقات
السعوديه الامريكيه بسبب انتقاد واشنطن
للرياض بخصوص سجلها في مجال حقوق الانسان
ومواءمه انتاجها النفطي مع روسيا وكذلك في
وقت تخيم حاله من عدم اليقين على اسواق
الطاقه بعد فرد القوى الغربيه حد الاقصى
لاسعار وردت النفط من روسيا التي زادت
شحنتها الى الصين بخصم في الاسعار حسب
البيت الابيض هذا اللقاء مثال على محاوله
بكين بسطه نفودها في منطقه الشرق الاوسط